and there's robert gazellman who gets
the start how deep he can go into this
game remains to be seen toyota even has
the numbers from last season gazelman's
season last year was interrupted by
right triceps tendonitis it was not
started on time because of right triceps
tendonitis but still now he's making the
start his first one in three years and
now washington with runners at first and
second soto comes in six for his last 14
home run number two came to the first
game of the series the longest of his
career here's a swing in a long drive
deep down the right field line and this
one hooking hooking towards the corner
it is a fair ball a three-run homer for
juan soto out of sight down the right
field line 466 they're telling me that's
farther than the other night it was 463.
so he tried to hit the apple the other
night
the cameraman couldn't even find this
one he hit it so far they're not used to
seeing him up on the concourse and now
we dance juan soto the longest home run
of his career nemo betting at 2 18. but
he's been getting on base so much he's
got the seventh best on base percentage
in the league nemo cracks one deep down
the line that ball is out here brandon
nimmo off the facing of the coca-cola
corner
his second home run in the series and
his third of the year and so the vets
strike right back it's now three to one
washington here comes pete alonso as the
tying run with two out in the first
inning three to one washington alonso
crushes one to the gap in right center
that's going to be in for a base hit
kenfordo on his way to third robles up
with the ball conforto coming to the
plate he will score without a relay
throw stopping at second with a double
and a run batted in is pete alonso and
it's now washington three of the mets
two now dom smith will bat with that
tying run at second dom floats one down
the right field line and that's a fair
ball it's gonna bounce into the corner
and tie the game and after the nets got
three in the top of the first the mets
have matched them in the bottom of the
first here's young mr jimenez and the
slow one is lined over short for a base
hit and the mets will grab the lead dom
smith is in to score ximena is able to
wait back on that butterfly and hit it
the other way to drive in a run of the
men's lead four to three full countdown
to the number eight hitter with victor
robles on deck high fly ball well hit
left center nimmo on the run with davis
they're back near the wall nemo jumps
and he made the catch
brandon nimmo right at the top of the
wall
but brandon nemo flashing some defense
what were we saying about defense up the
middle here two outs still two on and
wilson ramos will have a chance that's
it sharply base it for ramos around
third comes alonzo he heads for the
plate soto's throw goes to third dom
trying to get back to second and he does
safely it's an rbi single for wilson
ramos so the mets now lead five to three
so ramos who has really been struggling
especially with runners in scoring
position comes through with an rbi hit
with two out to extend the men's league
now you might have noticed when we came
on camera a moment ago that there's
treats that have come to the booth the
insomnia cookies have arrived you better
try them don't
ask me any questions when my mouth's
full
all right i hope it holds all right
i don't want your socks i'm just telling
you right now
well should i take those socks i don't
want your socks
conforto on base with two out here's
pete alonso who's doubled and walked
tonight he's driven in a run he's scored
two and lonza goes down to the high
fastball finnegan's got his first
strikeout and that'll end the game
roblox into scoring position at second
eaton heads to first and he chases for
strike three and familia works his way
out of trouble three strikeouts on the
inning for jay reese as he strands a
pair that's five nationals three juan
soto to lead off between a high blast to
left center field back on this one nimo
to left center at the track at the wall
and it's gone it's another home run for
juan soto this one in opposite field
blast to left center so soto has two
home runs and all four nats rbis that's
home run number four on the season it's
now a one run game first and third with
two down here's michael conforto
conforto cracks one to right eaton
coming over to right side it's over his
glove and rolls to the wall guillermo is
in no more round third being waved home
castro's thrown to the plate he slides
in safely
michael conforto with a two-run double
as eaton misplayed it in right center
and the mets now leads seven to four
it's a nine game hitting streak now for
conforto here's alonzo hit deep to left
field down the line gone if it's fair
and it is a fair ball homer on peter
luxo
lonzo's third homer the second hit of
the game and the mets now lead it nine
to four and here's dominic smith and now
dom smith hits one deep to right center
that ball is out of here
and now it's 10-4 new york
number three for dominic smith and the
mets have brought the hammer down here
in the sixth inning
and there's one away here in the top of
the eighth inning castro swings and
skies one in the air to right center
deeper back again conforto back hamilton
back conforto leaps and can't get it
it's gone goodbye
and it's now the match 10 of the
nationals five so two in scoring
position for dom smith has already got a
double a homer and two rbis tonight
and dom grounds went to first and
that'll bring a run in
so the mentor gifted a run on the ground
out by smith his third rbi of the night
as conforto comes home to make it 11-5
now the pitch to kurt suzuki hit of the
air to deep left field this is way back
mcneal up the wall leaping and it's gone
goodbye
bang zoom goes suzuki it's now the mets
11 and the national six
and just like that the nats are down to
their final out of the night he struck
him out on the ball game is over brad
brock puts on the finishing touches
seven pitchers combined for the win for
the vets